TIME-OUT LEFT, AND THAT'S
CRITICAL.
>> Jeff: AND AS WELL AS HE'S
SHOT FREE THROWS, YOU WANT TO
GET THE BALL IN TO KHRIS
MIDDLETON.
>> Mark: ABSOLUTELY.
OR JRUE HOLIDAY.
YOU WANT TO GET THE BALL IN TO
YOUR BEST FREE-THROW SHOOTER.
BECAUSE THESE ARE DIFFERENT
FREE-THROWS HE'S BEEN SHOOTING
ALL GAME LONG.
>> Mike: HE'S BEEN MAGNIFICENT
AT THE LINE.
50 POINTS.
ONLY THE SEVENTH PLAYER IN THE
HISTORY OF THE FINALS TO HAVE A
50-POINT GAME.
ELGIN BAYLOR, RICK BARRY,
MICHAEL JORDAN, JERRY WEST, BOB
PETTIT, AND GIANNIS
ANTETOKOUNMPO.
A RARE MISS TONIGHT.
AND THE SUNS WILL CALL THEIR
FINAL TIME-OUT, DOWN SEVEN WITH
8.9 REMAINING.
THE PLAYERS EXHAUSTED WILL GO TO
THEIR BENCHES.
THE MILWAUKEE BUCKS ON THE
VERGE.
8.9 SECONDS REMAIN IN WHAT HAS
BEEN ANOTHER THRILLING GAME
BETWEEN THESE TWO TEAMS.
FINALS FEATURING TWO TEAMS THAT
HAVE NOT BEEN HERE IN DECADES.
A FINALS WITHOUT THE FAMILIAR
STAR POWER THAT WE HAVE HAD IN
RECENT YEARS.
THAT'S WHAT I CALL STAR POWER.
AND THE HUGE SMILE.
THEY PUT THE CLOCK BACK TO 9.5
SECONDS.
50 POINTS, 14 REBOUNDS, 5
BLOCKED SHOTS, 50 OF 105 POINTS.
NEARLY HALF THE TEAM'S TOTAL.
NOW, JEFF, WITH 9.5 REMAINING, A
MIRACLE FINISH WOULD HAVE TO
HAPPEN FOR PHOENIX TO PULL IT
OUT, AND AGAIN, THEY'RE OUT OF
TIME-OUTS.
>> Jeff: THAT'S WHY YOU'VE GOT
TO CONCENTRATE ON THE DETAILS.
>> Mike: BOOKER, TURNS, SHOOTS,
FIRES.
SHOT WON'T GO.
TUCKER, THE REBOUND, AND THAT
WILL DO IT.
IT'S OVER.
THE BUCKS HAVE DONE IT.
THE LONG WAIT HAS ENDED AFTER A
HALF CENTURY.
THE MILWAUKEE BUCKS ARE NBA
CHAMPIONS ONCE AGAIN!
THE EMOTIONS COME POURING OUT.
ONE OF THE GREATEST NIGHTS IN
MILWAUKEE SPORTS HISTORY ENDS IN
A CORONATION.
AND THE BRILLIANCE OF THE YOUNG
MAN FROM ATHENS.
ANOTHER CRUSHING FINISH FOR
DEVIN BOOKER AND THE PHOENIX
SUNS AFTER A SUPERB SEASON.
THIS EXTRAORDINARY STORY OF THIS
EXTRAORDINARY YOUNG MAN.
GIVES HIM HIS NBA TITLE.
THE GREEK FREAK IS A GREEK NBA
CHAMPION.
GUYS, WE HAVE SEEN A LOT OF
AMAZING PERFORMANCES.
THIS RANKS AS ONE OF THE
ALL-TIME GREATEST.
>> Mark: IT ABSOLUTELY DOES.
WE WITNESSED LeBRON JAMES FOR SO
LONG.
BUT WE'VE SEEN A GUY PUT UP
LeBRON JAMES TYPE NUMBERS,
ESPECIALLY AFTER THE FACT THAT
HE WAS SUPPOSED TO BE OUT THE
REST OF THE WAY AFTER THAT SCARY
INJURY.
>> Jeff: AND THEN THE DEFENSIVE
COMPONENT AND EFFORT AND EXAMPLE
THAT HE SET.
HE WAS SPRINTING AND BLOCKING
AND RUNNING THE FLOOR.
AND THE ONLY GUY WHO HAD IT
GOING OFFENSIVELY.
THE BURDEN WAS GREAT, AND HE WAS
UP TO THE TASK.
>> Mike: P.J. TUCKER, ACQUIRED
MIDSEASON.
A BIG PART OF THE SUCCESS OF
THIS TEAM AND THE PLAYOFFS.
HE HAS SUCH A SENSE OF LOYALTY,
HIS FAMILY FIRST, BUT TO THE
BUCKS AND TO THE CITY OF
MILWAUKEE.
HE'S TALKED ABOUT EVERYONE HAS A
DIFFERENT PATH TO THE A TITLE.
I'M NOT JUDGING EVERYONE, BUT
FOR ME, I WANT TO DO IT FOR THE
TEAM THAT TOOK A CHANCE ON ME, A
CITY THAT WELCOMED ME, AND FOR A
TEAM T
>> Mike: THIS IS GOING TO BE
SOME WILD NIGHT IN DOWNTOWN
MILWAUKEE.
THE LAST TIME THE BUCKS WON A
CHAMPIONSHIP, 1971.
AGAIN, THEY'RE SAYING THAT'S
65,000.
HE WANTED TO DO IT IN THE CITY
THAT HE NOW CALLS HOME.
MISSION ACCOMPLISHED FOR GIANNIS
ANTETOKOUNMPO.
AND THIS IS ALWAYS THE FUN PART,
GUYS, THE